people of the internet's retro wrecking
tour here and we have some major major
Harry Potter magic awakened updates most
of them most of them are very very good
there's one that's kind of a little bit
annoying but after playing it all day I
think it is a really really solid update
with a lot of good changes so we're
going to take a look at some of those
now so to start off make sure you check
your mail because it looks like they
have sent us 2500 gold and also 13
silver keys for our patients during the
recent maintenance which is always nice
all right let's start on the positive
side because year three is officially
here that's right year three's in the
game I'm not gonna spoil anything now
other than we know the stories about
Daniel his mother and Azkaban I can't
wait to jump in that is by far I think
the biggest and best part of this update
right here is that year three is
officially in the game you can access it
right now alright so now let's take a
look at the brand new Forbidden Forest
because this is probably where the most
controversial change is and it's right
here with the Ford Anglia no longer you
guys will you receive any gold from the
Ford Anglia and this is really really
unfortunate because the Ford Anglia was
an incredible source of gold it was a
passive thing you could get it every
single day and gold is still valuable I
mean that is how you upgrade your cards
it's how you progress and level up in
the game the solo exploration side is
still here they've just changed up a
little bit how the rewards work so you
remember before you had to get to level
16 for example before you ever unlocked
the Bellatrix Echo you will still get a
Bellatrix Echo when you clear and hit
Level 16. however that's not the only
way to get that Echo now you don't have
to get that point to unlock the Bellator
set go there are other ways to do that
which we'll get to here in a second you
do still earn gold you do still earn
some rewards as you progress through
these unfortunately I mean the goal that
you're getting here nowhere close
nowhere close you guys to what the Ford
Anglia was able to put out the most
changes here in the Forbidden Forest are
by far on the right side the team
exploration modes deathly Dell is gone
haunted hollow is gone and they have
been replaced with these new modes which
in some ways it's a good change because
now you can sort of choose the specific
rewards that you want or at least a
certain pool of rewards that you want
for example here the first one Into the
Woods gold so right now you can see
based on my Spellbook level I would be
able to enter a level five and then
these would be the rewards that I would
be looking at if you hit the little I
there it's going to show you the full
clear rewards based on the level that
you're at now each day you can do these
two times
and you use a lantern to do that so the
lantern is a brand new currency in the
game you can see here they're going to
be distributed every day at 5am as many
as 10 lanterns can be held by a single
player at the same time so they can
stack up if you don't spin them all in
the same day you do still get thank you
notes even though whenever you try to go
in after using both your lanterns for
the day it will say do you want to do
this even though you don't get any
rewards they might want to change the
wording on that because at first I
thought oh wow this means that you don't
get anything but no you can go ahead go
through and you do still get thank you
notes as well which is really nice to
see now one more big change is even
though they have this inter solo button
right here you cannot enter solo anymore
unless I am just completely missing hit
here because if I try to enter solo it
pops up it says Hey solo Explorations
can be dangerous best invited companion
to go and then it will not let you
progress like even if I click this x
here I'm just right back where I was so
the only way to get in is by inviting
your companions here now at first I was
a little panicked because I didn't think
that it would allow us to invite friends
anymore more the plus it's over here now
so it has slightly moved positions a
little bit another nice positive change
is they have added matchmaking to this
activity so you can use companions if
you want you can invite your friends if
you want or you can match make with
other players from around the world
which is very very nice because as
awesome as it is to have the companions
a lot of times they just aren't a huge
help in the forest so being able to
match with other real world players is a
very nice change alright so let's look
at some of these other options here into
the woods number one we have this path
right here which will give you a chance
at the Snape Hermione or Neville Echoes
along with thank you notes as well and
then of course potion ingredients all
right then we have into the woods 2 here
this is the one you'll want to pick if
you want to go after Harry Newt or
Bellatrix then we have the final one
here into the woods three choose this
one if you want Dobby Hagrid or the
Weasley twins now the other Forbidden
Forest activity initially was not there
it's like they did the update and sort
of phases so when opelize first went
live we did not have the tangled web we
couldn't do it at all and then
throughout the day it looked like they
updated it now it is here so we have
everything at this point and you can see
the rewards here this one not quite as
good in my mind I mean it is nice you
can go in and get these Keys when you
progress all the way up here to the
final level six uh but it takes about
two weeks for it to reset so you can see
I've already done the first one here
I'll probably give the next one a try
really cool activity though I do think
both of them are quite a bit easier than
haunted hollow and deathly Dell now I'm
not to the upper levels yet so I'm only
on two right now one was really easy two
not too bad but even these I feel like
were a lot easier than nothing anywhere
approaching the difficulty that we saw
with deathly Dell which is kind of
unfortunate because I actually enjoyed
the challenge of that one and you know
it was very lengthy I enjoyed the
challenge of it had fun with some
friends trying to overcome it and we
finally did so maybe we'll see something
like that however when it comes to the
legendary Echoes this is just a huge
huge W with this update because I've
already gotten more just today than I
have basically the whole time playing
the game so that is a huge win and I'm
I'm really in favor of that and in my
opinion the next best thing as part of
this update is right here a brand new
league setting in the dueling club and
this is going to be absolutely
incredible especially for Content
creators and people who are part of a
community like in our Discord if you're
not yet part of it join in the video
description below you have three options
here on the left we have the rewards
match room custom room here in the
middle elimination match room on the
right so we're going to start with kind
of the easiest to understand and work up
to what I think is the coolest one so
right here we have custom room and this
is just quick you can hop in here with
two to four people three to five minutes
and it is just gonna be your basic
custom match settings here so you give a
name you can put a little lock and
require a password as well if you want
so we could say yes we want to set that
as the password balance mode I want to
do a little bit more experimenting on
all of these because balance mode is an
option in every single one of these I
was hoping that we'd have more options
than just setting it on or off I mean
maybe it's just going to magically work
to where everybody is automatically set
to the same level whenever you have this
balance mode enabled I hope that's how
it works because that would be great so
to level the playing field so that even
people who have really high level cards
are going to be brought down to the
level of maybe people who are just
starting out the game you do have
another tab here on the right for
detailed settings and this is going to
allow you to ban Echoes you can ban
cards you can also set your map
selection here and if you want to
require two out of three so best two out
of three wins you can allow spectating
as well and then you have this push to
channel option here which basically if
you click on the little I it's going to
give you some more information from the
way I read this I think that if you have
that enabled it's going to be easier for
people to find your room whereas if you
select no push means a player can only
enter through the list of rooms the room
number or via an invitation from the
host and then over here on the far right
we have bracket style elimination match
rooms for up to 16 players or 16 teams
if you want to do Duo now I am so
excited about this one because until I
started reading more details here I
didn't realize that it is set up in a
way that multiple games can be happening
at once so you don't all have to be
waiting for each match to finish you
don't have to watch every single match
you can see in this format players face
off against each other in a duel and the
loser is eliminated but then right here
that first sentence elimination matches
allow multiple players to participate at
the same time very very cool half of the
players are eliminated each round until
a final Champion emerges and then they
have the breakdown here of how it works
in Solo elimination versus Duo
elimination all right now the last one
which I'm actually the most excited
about and it's also the one that I was
most skeptical about in the beginning
because this one requires real world
money you say wait what requires real
world money well here's why it's awesome
because it will allow content creators
like myself to set up a room and give
you guys rewards for winning the
tournament this this is this is awesome
you know I mean I've always whenever
I've done tournaments in the past for
other games I've always tried to give
some kind of reward we've usually had to
do things like Amazon gift cards things
that are easy you know to give to
anybody but however here they're giving
you the option in game so like let's say
that I want to set uh this reward right
here so I want you to be able to get
this 1800 gold six mystery cards grants
a random common epic rare and then this
right here is the mystery bags you're
gonna get gold Echo crystals or gems so
let's say I just want to go for the max
one all these other settings here let's
just go ahead and put in test as a name
and we're definitely going to require a
password if we did this just put in some
random numbers there and then I want to
enable the balance mode detailed
settings we could go through that just
like we did with the other one but just
for the sake of showing you guys how
this works let's say I want to go with
this Max option right here then when I
hit create it actually pops up where I
would need to spin gems to buy a phoenix
flutter here and when I buy that that is
going to basically say that whoever wins
that tournament is going to get all
those rewards now
3280 that's a little steep let's see
what it is for this one here if we hit
create only 300 for that one okay so I
actually haven't even spent any money on
the game yet but I think this is a
really good opportunity for people who
want to create content on the game and
sponsor these tournaments to where
basically you're saying hey if you
participate in the tournament you can
actually win in-game rewards very very
cool and that's not the only updates
with dueling they also added a limited
time mode here looks like it's going to
be going on for about 13 more days so
roughly two weeks chocolate frog sweets
spree all right let's see if we can
actually figure this out okay they're
going after that Suite over there but
looks like Sirius caught them oh no oh
they got the sweet and it is sending out
some crazy damage right now look at this
look at this odd flavored sweets are
here oh
what man all right well that was
interesting I don't know that I love it
more than the usual duels but it's a
nice little change up now guys this is
just the beginning there are plenty of
additional updates coming including a
totally revamped magic pass with new
rewards looks like we're also going to
be getting some new cards soon as well
if you guys want to know my top 10 cards
for PVP right now that I already have a
video for that prepared for you it's
over on the right side of the screen now
as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon